I think the Darra certainly tensions.
There are certainly some skepticisms.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
there are some young people who wish the
old folks would stop talking about back
in the day.
Uh,
but that's true of all young people when
they talked to old people,
right?
It's not just a,
a true of our community,
it's true of all communities.
But one thing that I think is important
understanding is that there have been a,
there are generations in our community,
right?
And thank God for that.
Right?
Uh,
one of the things that's so tragic about
the lgbt community is that we have a
generation,
many of whom were lost to the AIDS
crisis.
And so unlike a lot of communities,
I think something that's very specific
to our community,
uh,
is that,
you know,
we have the stonewall generation that
was there,
the participate in the protests that
were part of that early,
uh,
uprising of gay liberation,
that are really feeling of,
of liberation that came out of that
movement.
Uh,
and then there was a period of time
where we lost a lot of our brothers and
sisters,
especially our brothers,
uh,
to the aids to aids.
And there is a pain there and there are
scars there that are,
that will never go away,
nor should they.
So this idea that we're all kind of free
and all this progress has been made and
that the young people in this generation
that are coming up now have no worries,
right?
The fact of matter is there are actually
rising std rates and rising HIV
infection rates in certain segments of
this generation.
A part,
certainly my young men of color,
young men in the African American and
Latino communities there arising HIV
rates among this members of this
generation.
Uh,
there are all sorts of considerations
that,
and struggles that this generation has
to,
has to work with.
And so,
and,
and the progress that's been made will,
will yield its own struggles,
right?
I mean,
you know,
it's one thing,
the struggle to earn the right to marry.
It's another thing to struggle to make
your marriage work.
Right?
Then once we have the right to marry,
then we're going to actually marry each
other and make it work.
And that's not easy,
right?
Nobody's ever been married,
will ever tell you that.
I mean,
what's the biggest crisis of the,
uh,
the,
the worst thing that's happened as a
result of the goodrich decision in
Massachusetts is that the good rich has
got divorced,
right?
You know,
and,
and you know,
and I,
I feel badly for them,
but the end of the day,
like that court ruling was named after a
lesbian couple that were heralded as
heroines of our movement.
And they should have been,
they were very,
very important,
but they're now divorced,
right?
So that's its own struggle is to figure
out how to make families,
how to make our families work,
how to marry each other and love each
other and stay true to each other.
And that's,
that's a human struggle,
right?
That's a human struggle that transcends
all histories in all communities.
Uh,
and it's one that this generation is
going to have to struggle with in a way
that other generations have never had to
because they didn't have the right to.
But these reits also will,
we'll bring out their own struggles.
And I mean,
I see this all the time.
Uh,
and,
you know,
so I think we all need to be more alert
to the differences that we,
uh,
experience and,
and,
and give witness to based on where we
are in history.
But I think we also have to understand
that,
you know,
we all have struggles and as a result,
we are all struggling people.
And that,
that should be able to elicit a certain
kind of empathy that can sustain us,
I think,
more strongly and more deeply than it
than it currently does.